herzlich willkommen bei pixum ich würde
mal sagen eine high-class denn jetzt
gibt es bei uns nur noch gäste vom
feinsten und der erste ist die comedy
herzlich willkommen bei kiki und bei uns
immer die erste frage als klar wie steht
die uhr
so ähnlich was ich das sofa die lage
katastrophal recht warum keine wohnung
mehr keine freundin mehr und kein auto
mehr
aber das ist ja nicht so schlimm dass
katastrophen recht warum ich jetzt
nichts mehr ab christoph aber das tolle
ist ja wenn man in so einer
lebenssituation ist man zieht dafür
comics oder so siehst ja auch guck mal
da ihr habt mich jetzt zu hause besucht
in der tiefgarage
wir holen hier lebe ich okay nicht mehr
im kader
und ich dachte das wäre unfug tiefgarage
ich habe müssen irgendwie bleibe suchen
naja ich gedacht so gut die tonne da
kann ich mich umziehen
die tonne ist toll habe ich selber schon
super nanny mir geht es gut die lage ist
gut das heißt von der geburt bis zu
eritrea aber eigentlich in deutschland
aufgewachsen und kannst alle dialekte
nein das stimmt nicht wieviel 123 14 15
16 24 26 und 27
37 38 40 41 240 so ungefähr 44
dann fehlt nur noch ein unglaublich bist
du kannst ja wie viele dialekte wie hast
du dich drauf geschafft also bat
guttenberg wisse ja zuerst geworden groß
geworden
quasi mit der muttermilch auch nicht
mehr mit dem mit der muttermilch habe
ich bekommen eine mischung aus
elektrischen deutschen probieren
schwäbisch zurück und sprach so eine
mischung aus allem so ein ausländer
deutsch dass man hat keine arbeit von
seiner familie zum beispiel kann man
einem interne ein auto beim hatte aber
viel dokumentation gesehen und habe
gemerkt dass ich mich extrem verbunden
gefühlt haben richtig obwohl ich das
land ja nicht so gut ich bin hier groß
geworden ich war einmal dort und sowieso
zu dem afrikanischen kontinent ich bin
ziemlich ruft daher sehe ich mich in
afrika reise machen kannst du dir
vorstellen dort zu leben also in afrika
ja also alle wenn ich mal älter bin
diese pendeln paar monate dort wieder
zurück
also ich will hier in deutschland
bleiben aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
so mit meiner frau zusammen
hast du eine frau 4 vj 44
mit welcher möchtest du dann nach
eritrea keiner zum ist eine irakische
frau dort haben möchte dort eine
aufkaufen und deine frauen hier die
dieses leben in der gleichen stadt oder
in verschiedenen städten das muss man
trennen
ja ich glaube dieses dass man teilt
grundsätzlich dass man wenn man zusammen
ist dass man zusammen ist so das ganze
ganz normal bei uns david nicht da sitzt
keiner am tisch und ist alleine das gibt
es bei uns nicht
essen alle zusammen und das ist glaube
ich so oder dass man was zu essen
anbietet 500 mal hintereinander wird
zuerst nein danke danke also gar keine
gedanken so angepasst
aber das ist ja ich liebe deutschland
extreme und ich weiß auch dass es nicht
selbstverständlich ist dass wir so gut
leben wie wir leben in deutschland gut
dass uns dass wir sie wollen nicht
sorgen müssen zum thema geben
es gibt richtig gut dass du dir schon
mal darüber gedanken machen da mache ich
mir das ist unglaublich das ist so
deswegen also ich bin ich probiere jeden
ich sag mir wirklich fast jeden tag
gedacht habe was mit arbeit ist
vergessen am gelben fast jeden tag so
dankbar sein mit mit wirklich
kleinigkeiten ich habe eine wohlig kommt
nach hause ich kann mir was zuerst zu
machen
ich kann mich waffen ich kann machen was
ich dinge die für uns selbstverständlich
erscheint sind in anderen ländern da
musst du keine ahnung wer muss so
richtig glück haben um so leben zu
können oder irgendwelche connections
oder geld einfach nur deswegen
ich bin wirklich also ich wünsche mir
dass ich in filmen in großen
produktionen auch wirklich eine schöne
rollen spielen darf
aber so den traumjob traumjob habe ich
kann ich möchte mich einfach ich wünsche
mir dass ich das machen kann was weiß
ich was ich gerade mache die möglichkeit
meine tour zu spielen
eine show zu machen dass meine videos
macht und so und ich habe die chance
leute zum lachen zu bringen
ich habe unbedingt das erreichen habe
ich gar nicht glücklich so wie es gerade
ist und wenn
sich noch andere türen öffnen ist cool
und wenn nicht wird sich irgendwas
anderes ergeben oder es wird schon einen
grund haben warum das ist aber ich bin
da echt ich bin zufrieden und glücklich
mit dem